[Music]
hello everyone
i am elizabeth schneider senior global
marketing manager here at nana string
and welcome to today's webinar
sponsored by nana string and presented
through lab roots so we have the
pleasure of having two presenters today
firstly we will have
vic devgen
who is senior director of spatial
genomics business unit at manistering
technologies
and he will introduce the cosmic spatial
molecular imager spatial biology at
single cell resolution
and he will be followed by
dr chen
zhao who's an assistant clinical
investigator medical oncologist
immunologist physician scientist at the
center for cancer research national
cancer institute at the nih
and he will be presenting
on interrogating tumor immune
interactions in aml patients receiving
immune checkpoint inhibition treatment
so today we encourage you to participate
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
so let me introduce
vic
so um dr devgen is a senior director of
spatial genomics business at nanostring
technologies and he received his phd in
molecular biology and conducted
postdoctoral research at harvard before
moving to the biotechnology industry
he also received an mba from the
university of verseburg in germany and
has spent many years as a scientist
developing new technologies and products
for clinical and translational research
thank you so much vic for joining us
we're looking forward to your
presentation
thanks elizabeth uh hello everyone
welcome to uh nanostring spatial biology
webinar
comprehensive understanding of spatial
biology require integration of
information at three different
resolutions
multicellular
single cell and subcellular level
nanostring is dedicated to 12th spatial
solution for all three spatial
resolutions
we already have geomic dsp platform
available in our market
geomic dsp with its whole transcriptome
analysis and high throughput has become
a
method of choice for multi-cellular
special analysis
earlier this year we have launched our
second spatial platform called cosmic
spatial molecular imager
cosmics enables spatial analysis at
single cell and subcellular level
in my talk today i am going to focus
mutually on cosmic smi so let's start
with what does cosmic smi do
cosmics enable
quantification and visualization of
thousand-plex rna
100-plex protein
expression level at single cell and
subcellular level in a morphologically
intact tissue
you are looking at raw data coming out
of cosmic instrument with melanoma
tissue ffp section
here teal colored lines represent
well-defined cell boundaries of single
cells
and these tiny dots are images of rna
transcripts one dot is equal to a one
rna transcript so you are getting a
complete digital quantification
cosmics enable
quantification of more than billion
transcripts across a half a million
cells in a one single run
and that is the power of cosmics
now we all are well aware of single cell
rna-seq technology it's a good
technology at the end it yields cell
types as well as genes associated with
different cell types
but what it cannot provide is the
information about where these cell types
are located
and how they are interacting with each
other
and that's where cosmetics comes into
the play
cosmics fills that gap and enable
analysis of both
cosmic not only provide the cell types
but also the exact physical location of
these cell types
once you have spatially resolved gene
expression map at a single cell
resolution you can start asking multiple
different biological questions
but before jumping into the applications
of cosmics let's look at how cosmic smi
works
cosmic uses single molecules in situ
hybridization chemistry
both rna as well as protein targets are
identified by
in-situ hybridization of specific probes
or antibodies linked to our dna barcode
as shown here as a readout domains
and these readout domains are decoded by
cyclic imaging of flow descent drag
reporters
cosmic needs up to a five probes per
chain
and the target binding domain of these
probes are very small just 35 to 50
nucleotide long
and that is why cosmix works beautifully
with small transcript as well as with
ffb sample with relatively degraded rna
now let me walk you through what cosmic
does in a detail
so please keep in mind everything is
automated and you don't have to worry
about any of these but to introduce the
concept i have
divided the whole process into a six
different steps
so you start with tissue section on a
standard morphology standard pathology
slide
and
after a very simple sample processing
you upload that slide onto an instrument
whole process start with a very rapid
low resolution scan of the whole slide
to detect or locate where the tissue
section is
and then the tissue section is overlaid
by the morphology marker staining
cosmics has
five optical channel it uses four for
protein based morphology marker staining
including cell membrane staining and
fifth for dappy based nuclear staining
up front morphology markers staining
provide a great flexibility for cosmic
users
it enables researchers to do either
analyze the whole tissue section or
focus on a small biologically relevant
tissue area based on the morphology
marker stains and get a higher
throughput
once you have selected a tissue area
cosmics goes through a cyclic imaging
process
and generate a
composite image of all transcript of
targeted genes
then
cosmic uses data driven cell
segmentation method and define accurate
and precise
single cell boundaries
as shown over here
followed by that cosmic allocate
detected transcript to single cell with
well-defined boundaries
and once you have this information in
your hand you can start building
different biological stories
for example you can use our cell typing
and mapping algorithm
and define a cell atlas of the whole
tissue section
as shown here with a non-small cell lung
cancer tissue ffp sample
the cosmic analyze around 120 000 cells
in 20 millimeter square tissue area
and detected around 18 different cell
types including four subtypes of t cells
power of cosmic is it is a true single
cell in situ expression analysis system
so you can validate all your cell types
by visualizing expression of cell type
marker at a single cell level
and seeing is believing right so you can
publish your result with very high
confidence
now imagine you have such a data from
1000 genes and you can select any gene
or a set of gene visualize their
expression entire the whole tissue
section
at a single cell resolution
and then you can start asking different
biological questions
as an example this is a study done by
jay cass's lab from ossu
so they are interested in understanding
effect of certain pharmaceutical drug on
a sib infection
they used cosmic to analyze
treated and controlled lymph nodes of
siv infected rhesus monkey
cosmic detected 14 different cell types
and four tissue micro environment niches
in a lymph node tissue
further analysis indicated that
these siv infected cells are majorly or
predominantly located in a b cell
follicle of control lymph nodes
and they are dramatically or drastically
reduced in a treated lymph nodes
as they have shown here with a red
colored dot so regular dots are siv
infected
cells
and in addition to uh in addition to
that cosmic enable researchers for the
first time ever to distinguish between
productively infected cells from the
uninfected cells
and this has made possible because of
the super resolution of cosmics
cosmics has 55 0 nanometer resolution on
x y axis
and around 200 nanometer resolution on c
axis
because of such a high resolution
researchers can easily visualize
siv gene expression in the cytoplasm of
productively infected cells
whereas in uninfected cells these siv
gene expression is located or trapped in
a plasma membrane
however the power of cosmic is its high
plaques
which enable researchers to not only do
cell typing
and neighborhood analysis but also allow
a deep dive into the biology
as researchers used the thousand-plex
cosmic panel to define siv infection
biomarkers based upon a spatial location
additionally cosmic has very high
sensitivity
it enables detection of
low special medium expresso as well as
high expresso
cosmic has a
very high dynamic range of around five
blocks
and enable detection of hundred of
transcript per cells
as shown here with an study done by a
grand caller's lab from university of
saint louis
so they are interested in defining cell
atlas of human eyelid of longer hands
they analyzed more than million cells
across nine different samples and
detected more than 500 transcript per
cells
cosmic enable detection of 22 different
cell types in a pancreatic tissue of
human
our this project is focused on our
endocrine cells and cosmic has
successfully detected
pancreatic beta cells alpha cells as
well as relatively rare delta cells
researchers used cosmic to define cell
atlas of more than 400 eyelets of longer
hence
and the cellular composition of these
eyelets varies from uh based upon a you
know
a human population or a groups
in a normal group
eyelets are majorly consist of endocrine
cells
and beta cells are the predominant cell
population
whereas in a type 2 group
type 2 diabetic group these eyelids are
infiltrated by other cell types
including measle chemical fibroblasts
endothelial cells
and it's important to note that
researchers are able to make this
observation only because of the spatial
analysis
as the the dissociated single cell
rna-seq
technology
with that technology researcher would
have lost that information
the most drastic
difference has was observed with
metabolically healthy obese human group
here eyelets are very large in a size
and predominantly consists of alpha
cells
so so far i have talked about rna
capability of cosmics
our rna is not the whole world protein
is equally
important if not more
and you need high plex rna analysis to
define uh or to understand the
comprehensive function
of cells but at the same time you need a
high plex protein analysis to get the
absolute architectural understanding of
a tissue
and cosmics provide both high plexus rna
and high plex protein analysis
cosmic has already demonstrated
404 plaques protein analysis at a
sub-cellular level
i would like you to concentrate on a
lower left-hand image
here her2 expression is highlighted with
a yellow color and it is predominantly
located on a plasma membrane
whereas fancy k is highlighted here with
a pink color and predominantly located
in a cytoplasm
whereas nuclear is changed with tapi in
blue
so this image beautifully indicates
sub-cellular resolution of cosmics
in addition to a multi-atomic capability
cosmics also provide a tunable
throughput
cosmic enable analysis of up to 1000
targets across 300 millimeter square
tissue area
with a throughput of 2 to 20 slides per
week
cosmic is designed to enable both
discovery and translational research
you can use cosmic to analyze let's say
up to thousand target with the hundred
millimeter square area and two with the
two slides per week
and on the other hand you can also
select to use cosmic to analyze 100
targets with a more biologically focused
area let's say around 16 millimeters
here with up to 20 slides per week
so flexibility is with the researchers
the one thing to keep in our mind is
cosmic throughput is inversely
proportional to the plex and tissue scan
area
additionally cosmics provide robust data
with all different sample types
with
ffp tissues tissue microarrays
organoids as well as fresh frozen
tissues
we have recently finished analysis of
the whole tissue section of mouse brain
fresh frozen samples
here is a sneak peek of the the data
so cosmic detected around 46 distinct
cell type in a mouse brain
including astrocytes neurons
oligodendrocytes glias and so many more
and stay tuned to learn more about this
data in coming days
so this is my last slide
um
in summary cosmic provide highest plex
tunable throughput
ffp compatibility multi-ohmic
compatibility but on the top of that
cosmic provide completely integrated
easy to use system
its sample prep is very simple and easy
uh it's based upon a standard ish
protocol
there is no tissue cleaning required
there is no gel embedding required there
is no amplification required
you can do a very simple sample prep and
upload that slide onto our instrument
and
cosmic has an integrated high resolution
microscope
so
you
you don't need any additional instrument
to conduct your experiment
above all
cosmics comes with a cloud-based
scalable compute and storage solution
and it has all the data analysis modules
integrated into a cloud-based solution
so that you can get you know one touch
button all the data ounces from cosmic
star
with that
i would like to thank for your time
thank you
thanks so much vic
so
introduce dr chen zhao
so dr chen zhao is a medical oncologist
immunologist and physician scientist
focusing on tumor immunology and
immunotherapy
he specializes in developing novel
immunotherapies and using advanced
tissue imaging techniques and spatial
transcriptomic analyses to understand
the three-way interactions among tumor
cells the immune system and the microbes
in the tumor microenvironment over the
course of cancer initiation progression
and therapeutic response
and as i mentioned earlier dr chen or
sorry dr zao will be presenting on
interrogating tumor immune interactions
in aml patients receiving immune
checkpoint inhibition therapy thank you
so much dr sao we're looking forward to
your presentation
thank you the best
hello everyone i'm chen zhao i'm
assistant clinical investigator from nci
so today we i would like to share our
research on interrogating the tumor
immune interaction in ml patients
receiving immune checkpoint inhibitors
so this
all about our research should not be
considered as any endorsement of any
products
so as we know uh aml uh just like
this slide is a summary of all different
types of cancer and the uh
cancer related tests through the over
the years and you can see we have
already achieved a tremendous
improvement of the lung cancer treatment
the cancer-related diet was
significantly
decreased however leukemia stills they
are very
lethal disease and actually there is a
minimal improvement
as we know
uh
in the normal uh bone marrow this is a
normal hematopoiesis and the blood cells
the myeloid cells the lymphocyte they
all generated from the hematopoietic
stem cells and then they go to the
progenitors the precursors and when in
the
in the aml settings and certain lineage
will stop uh differentiation and
the cell population will significantly
increase then you will see a lot of aml
blast this is a leukemia cells
circulating in the patient's blood or in
the bone marrow
so the treatment of aml has a
significantly improved over the years
however
the treatment response is still
mainly dependent on patient genetic
abnormality which was mainly determined
by the
the
tumor intrinsic properties
however we know that the bone marrow
transplant actually transplant a
donor's bone marrow to the recipient can
greatly improve the patient response
especially in those patients who
achieved a complete response after the
chemotherapy they do much better than
those who did not
and this is just a brief summary of
different bone marrow
transplant strategies and
in aml settings where many use
allogenetic chemotherapy stem cell
transplant
so
uh this background actually tell us uh
the
tumor immune interaction especially when
you bring someone else donors
hematopoietic cells the
graft versus the leukemia effect can
significantly improve the survival
so based on this uh knowledge this
findings
dr chris horrigan from uh uh
nhlbi nih i actually developed this
clinical protocol to treat the aml
patient with the pembolismite which is
the immune checkpoint in hebrew
attacking the pd1
receptors and hypermaxinating agent
dissecting which is a traditional
aml treatment reagent for refractory or
relapse aml
this is just here i'm presenting a brief
summary of the 12th patient will receive
primarily smite on the day one and then
patient will receive that setting on the
date
8 to 12 and 15 to
19 in cycle 1 three five seven so
basically we are combining the
checkpoint inhibitors with
hypermycinating agent
so the
this trial also has a very special
design it allows us to obtain the bone
marrow biopsy at the baseline or after
the checkpoint treatment or after the
combination treatment
and the result of the
initial analysis of trial has already
been published
earlier this year and as we can see
there are a few several patients who
achieve a complete response so this is
very exciting in this patient population
because in the in the past the
refractory or relapse aml patient is
responsibly to the
treatment
so
as i mentioned before the trial give us
a unique opportunity to look into the
tumor immune interactions what does that
mean
because we can do the bone marrow biopsy
and just a brief introduction like about
the bone marrow biopsy procedures so we
put the needles into the bone and
the operator will draw the aspirate
which is contains
the bone marrow stem cells the leukemia
cells
and
later after aspiration we will also
obtain a biopsy which is a piece of the
bone that contains the bone marrow
so the difference between these two is
that all the cells here in the aspirate
the cells are isolated they are not in
the intact environment so this will be
analyzed with a with a single cell
analysis uh
platform such as tanax
allow us to look into the transcriptomes
or nowadays with the cyclic you can also
look at the surface proteins
and
on the other side with a bone marrow
biopsy it's intact tumor micro
environment
and this is showing you an example we
look at the under the hie staining and
this pink part is the bone part and like
to you you can later on we will zoom in
to look at the leukemia cells and immune
cells this is a staining of cd34 which
is the marker for the leukemia cells as
well as for the hematopoietic stem cells
so in this study most of the patient or
the patient we selected they have cd35
expression on the leukemia cells
so this allows us to look into this
tumor micro environment so the pink
cells here this cd34 positive cells
these are leukemia cells and you can see
they cluster together and surrounding it
is
those are the cells with the blue
nucleus those are the stroma cells they
can be immune cells or other progenitor
cells
so as you can see here these are
leukemia cells that express cd34
and the the interaction between the
leukemia cells and this uh
this black arrow point cells probably is
not as important as the leukemia cell
with its neighboring cells so in this
scenario this the distance
really matters and we really need to
understand how the surrounding cells
interact with the leukemia cells
so this problem to our hypothesis that
the leukemia cells uh actually interacts
more with the nearby nearby cells
especially the t cells and the immune
checkpoint inhibitors will change the
cell properties in the surrounding cells
so
we really want to know what are the
cells near the tumors so sorry
near the tumors and
whether they're different from the cells
that are far away from the tumors
so uh
we started with using the uh the digital
spatial profiler the geomets platform as
a just a brief introduction it's it's a
probe based hybridization platform which
actually allows the users to select the
signal the mr
the probes near the protein certain
protein markers
so in this way first we want to know how
are we going to define the near and far
so using the traditional ihd staining we
can identify those cd34 expressing
leukemia cells and we can also i
identify the surrounding cells
so we measure all the distance and we
see there is significant increase of the
enrichment of cells
near the
within 20 microns from the leukemia
cells so in this
initial study we decided to define the
nearby t at the nearby cells by a
distance of 20 microns
then we need to i use the imaging based
pipeline to identify those cells so this
is exactly how we did the experiment so
on every single slide we have uh three
samples
one is uh from the same patient one that
baseline this the other one is a post
immune checkpoint inhibitors which after
the pamprolizumab treatment on base
eight and then later on we have another
bone marrow samples the top one it's
also the post hypomaxine methylating
agent the dissecting treatment
and we stay in this slide with the
cytosol team which should
show all the nucleus cg34 the leukemia
cells in this setting and cd3 it will be
the t cells
this is just assuming of the rights we
select
you can see the blue nucleus cd34 uh
leukemia cells and the cd3 those yellow
those t cells
some of you may notice there are this
kind of like big like strikes of uh
red signals those are the blood vessels
so in the in the bone marrow the blood
vessel they're also possible for cd34
so this gives us a very challenging task
so uh we have 19 ris per slide and in
order to collect all the samples we want
to process them in six as one hour 16
minutes during this 16 minutes uh period
of time we need to remove the background
the source noise and as i you can also
see we also need to remove those blood
vessels those are also positive for cd34
34 and we need to segment the cells
at the beginning we try to just use the
distance but as you can imagine if you
purely use a distance to draw to do a
circle you may you you will absolutely
cut a lot of cells into half and this
will contaminate your analysis
and during this process you also need to
identify the cell type which one is
leukemia cells which one t cell which
are the other cells and by the end you
need to
we also need to measure the distance
yes
so this is a this is a very challenging
job in order to do this actually we
develop a ai-based algorithm using a
neural network which actually allows us
to remove the background
remove the blood vessel do the instance
segmentation and identify different cell
types based on the surface markers and
then perform the clustering as you can
hear see here this is the image that
process
after the
imaging analysis pipeline and we can
separate the t cells into the near and
far the margin the magenta cells uh and
all the fast far t cells those are the
uh in the cells in green and leukemia
cells is in white
and the other cells those are the cells
that do not express 34 or cd3 they also
uh they also are divided into near and
far
so in general this is our study design
we have the baseline post pembro and
poster dissecting we have three time
points and we identify the cell types
based on the surface micro expression
leukemia cells positive four cyto13
positive for 30 34 but negative for
cd3 t cells that are possible for cd3
and non-t cells those are the stoma
cells that are positive uh for satellite
only negative for both cd34 and cd3
and then we also have the spatial
location which is the center and then
the nearby the cells within 20 micron or
the cells more than 20 microns
so
this is a very live study after the qc
controls uh six patients
pass qc we have different cell segments
and here's just just brief uh
introduction about the result
so as we can see there is dynamic change
of the leukemia cells after
at a different
time point on the left figure here on
the left side is the leukemia cells
after the checkpoint and the relative on
the right is that the baseline you can
see there are multiple genes within
reach so it suggests the checkpoint
works and probably this effect you are
seeing here this is like the actually
the checkpoint or what
probably work on the t cells which i
will show you later on and this t cell
attacks the leukemia cells
and the the middle figure is compared to
the effect from the dissecting versus
the
effect from the
immune parallelism and on the right side
you can directly compare
the baseline which is on the right side
versus the leukemia cells that's after
the combination therapy which on the
left side
so the most exciting part actually from
our study is it enables us to look into
the t cells at the different locations
so here this is a result of the t cell
of transcription change at a different
time points and
at a different location the upper rows
show you the t cells near the leukemia
cells the
the lower rows show you the t cells and
those are far away from the leukemia
cells
so we will start from the upper left
which is the baseline comparison to the
after checkpoint as you can see multiple
genes were enriched after the checkpoint
in the t cell near the nearest leukemia
cells relatively if you
look at
the plot under it is a t cell far away
from the leukemia cell source of the t
cell 20 micron away you see way less
genes or enriched
so we are still in the process of uh i
analyze this data and in the middle part
you can see after the hypermaxillating
agent well multiple genes actually uh
the effect diminished
and if we put all the genes in reach
after checkpoint into a pathway analysis
actually it made a lot of sense you see
multiple pathways involving the
cytokines
production interferon alpha and even the
l18 they were enriched in this group of
t cells after the checkpoint treatment
and the
here this is the comparison of the
different t cell locations at a
different time point on the left side
this comparison between the t cells that
are far away which is uh
which is on the left side what's the t
cells near the leukemia cells you can
see the harvest drama like uh
some difference but after the checkpoint
treatment which is the middle figure you
see the significance in reach of
multiple genes involved in the cytokine
and cytotoxic toxicity activity enriched
in the t cells near the near the
leukemia cells
and when you compare to other cells at a
different time point you see we like
realized genes which here is also such
this might be caused by the effect
actually other cells it can
contain different cell compartment
to further look into this uh
effect actually we use the
the simultaneous obtained single cell
rna sequencing data did the spatial
deconvolution and we
when we look into the t t-cell subset
actually we see there are dimensions
there are a huge variety among different
patients and there is also dynamic
exchange after the checkpoint at
different spatial locations
this is also
true for other cell types uh like we
also perform the decon spatial
deconvolution into the other cells and
you can also see dramatic differences
after the checkpoint treatment also at a
different
spatial locations
so in summary from our dsp study when we
divide the t cell to uh
like to the near and
far different groups based on the
spatial location the 20 microns so the t
cell next to the leukemia cells they
have a very unique transcriptional
profile and the immune checkpoint will
definitely significantly affect the t
cell next to the leukemia cells and
those
agents that i said
the dissector let me change the t-cell
property and this also deserves further
investigation
however here as vic mentioned earlier so
this
we divide the cells just properly into
two big groups based on a half cut off
like 20 micron definitely we want to
zoom in to the single cell spatial
resolution to unbiasedly study the
spatial relationship
so we use the cosmic platform as
we mentioned before this is a probe
based platform using the barcoding
strategy which allows us to look at the
transcription level at
a single cell spatial resolution
so we perform the study with the exactly
same batch of samples and we look at the
three time points look into the core and
for each core we have this field of view
and we can stain uh for the surface
markers and here the magentas are
showing the enrich actually just
showing all the genes and you can see
different
spots enriched in the in the leukemia
genes cells and the t cells
in general on from each core we have
around 50
50 000 cells and we have a read uh
read uh counts
varies between 100 to 200
and this spatial technology actually
allow us to also unbias class
cells in the tumor microenvironment into
different clusters this is a different
clustering algorithm and we were able to
annotate identify the t cells the
cumulative cells the myeloid cells
and
we can see the hybrids are very dramatic
different spec transcriptomes
and the the cell numbers they also
varies and we are in the process of
connecting the different modality and
the spatial information with our a
single cell data set
so in general i think uh
with the dsp platform we were able to
see the dramatic difference between the
the t cells after the before and after
the checkpoint treatment now
with a single this new platform we were
able to zoom in to look into the exactly
uh single cell spatial resolution that's
how the t cells interact with the
leukemia cells
and then
i would like to
thank
my mentor ron germain for this
opportunity and also i would like to
thank my students my team that
abigail juan roli who actually performed
the study and i would like also to thank
our clinical uh
collaborator uh chris dr chris horrigan
and gigi grey from etopia
thank you so much dr sao and so we had a
number of questions that came in through
the q and a window throughout the
presentation
so we'll go ahead and start with um one
question for you um dr sao
using the same samples how did your
geomix dsp data guide your cosmic smi
pilot study
yeah i think uh this
is a good question i think that there
are two aspects so first like
as i can show you earlier so the we
actually perform the dsp study on
multiple patients and we there are only
six patients past the qc so first we
should only select the patient who has a
qc from dsp for our cosmic
the smi study
and second the dsp itself also
provided us a guide to
lead our analysis to focus on the t
cells especially the transcription
analysis so i think these two major
parts that our dsp
study
actually helped our cosmic smi study
excellent thank you so much another
question that came in for vic
[Music]
can you explain the value of imaging the
whole tissue section with single cell
resolution
uh yes i mean
a whole tissue section you know it's uh
when you're analyzing the whole tissue
section it takes a guess work out of the
experimentation
uh you are generating data in a unbiased
manner and then uh you know during the
later during a data step you will have
more flexibility to select whichever
region or a tissue area you want so you
are not missing anything you are
basically analyzing everything in one
shot itself
thank you for that vic so we'll go back
to um dr sao as
um what do you presume the distinct cell
clusters found through your cosmic smi
pilot study indicate is biologically
occurring in the tumor micro environment
in aml
yes
so this is a good question i think the
several distinct classes we found
especially the t cells i think it
suggests that like even in the tumor
micro environments t-cells still form
clusters they do not go along they talk
to each other it's there might be two
possibilities that actually we are like
uh we are pursuing now one is that the
leukemia cells near that group class of
t cells they are very different they
have harvest different antigens or have
they have different cytokine mutuals so
this is one possibility second is that t
cells is there might be this cytokine to
cytokine talking effect the t cells may
talk to each other and enable the
function of surrounding nearby
non-specific t-cells yeah
all right thank you for that dr xiao um
we have another question um for vic
um
can you elaborate on some of the
applications of cosmic smi specifically
as it relates to the platform
multi-omics capabilities
yeah um
so
actually i mean when we're talking about
the application of cosmics you know it's
a it has very broad application so
uh just think about everything what the
single cell rna seq can do
cosmics can do that in addition on top
of that it's going to do that provide
all that information with the spatial
context
so think about all the cell atlasing
work like discovery and map of cell
types their cell state fractionalization
uh on a protein site as well as for the
rna like phenotyping of tissue
microenvironment understanding the
neighborhood niches and how the
you know different
looking into a differential expression
of cell types with a spatial context
again
uh characterizing whole ligand receptor
uh
interaction um
then i will even the you know when
you're looking at the subcellular level
especially on the protein side the
subcellular level uh uh quantification
of the protein is really play a very
important role in different biological
processes and you can achieve that and
get that
with cosmetics
excellent thank you so much
another question for you dr sao
let's see can you provide additional
details about the development of the
neural networks using geomex dsp and ai
assisted imaging analysis pipeline
and possibly how cell type masking on
dsp assisted with this
yes so
actually
we are like in the manuscript
preparation for the algorithm so but in
general uh the idea is that the uh the
images was processed at different layers
and we also we use the pixel based uh uh
classification to remove some of the
background and also the blood vessels
and then we use the like state of art
the cell segmentation tool and then the
cell identity was defined based on the
protein marker expression and we
obtained the raw image from a dsp
platform and then we process our base uh
immediate
analysis pipeline and then we
actually put the mask back to the dsp
platform which will enable us to collect
those signals
excellent thank you so much so another
question for you vic
is the cosmic smi
process non-destructive to the tissue
sections and then also
um can you customize the probes
both for rna and protein
yes so i'll take that
you know the last question first uh yes
the both rna and protein customization
uh is possible with the cosmetics so
cosmics on rna side is going to have
three different flavors one is we are
going to have a well predefined uh uh
you know panels catalog panels which uh
uh which can buy uh directly and on top
of that the second flavor will be uh you
know customers have a few
gene of interest or failure on which
they have been working on from quite
some time they can add on uh around 50
genes
on the top of our thousand plex rna
panel
uh so it's it's more like you have the
well-defined panel but at the on the top
you are adding your custom jeans on top
of it and the third flavor is
you can
define your completely dino
panel you can come up with the with us
with your chain list and what you have
to do is just provide us that gene list
and we can develop the we can define
those probes and the manufacturers and
validate it and send that
to researchers so it's a complete there
are different three different flavors
including complete customization and for
rna side and we will have the same thing
on a protein side
we will have customization of proteins
specifically add-ons to our catalog
protein panels
uh available or in a q1 of 2023.
excellent thank you so much and then the
first part of the question was um is the
process you're going to slide
non-destructive yeah so uh it's uh
it's a little bit about how we define
non-destructive you know
we are we can analyze its rna and then
on the top of that we can analyze both
rna and protein on the same slide and if
you want to redo and use this slide to
do that some kind of uh
you know bulk analysis you can scrap
everything and do the bulk analysis
whether it's on dna side or rna side
that can be done
okay excellent so it sounds like in that
respect it's very similar to the geomets
dsp platform
excellent so we'll close with a question
for um dr xiao
and what kind of insight does combining
spatial profiling data with single star
rna seq data provide
yes this is also another very good
question so we feel that like single
cell data definitely i think the
circuits in depth is much much deeper
however the major question we had in the
past is like we never know whether
actually those isolated t-cells didn't
interact with the leukemia cells the
tumor cells so i think this is like a
major advantage actually we use this we
developed an algorithm to combine the
multi-modalities this multi-ohmic
strategy to put them together and to
enable that actually
identify those t-cells
profiles near the leukemia cells
thank you very much um so it looks like
this is going to conclude the q a
session
um so um vic and um
chen do you guys have any final comments
for our audience
and thanks thanks a lot uh for your time
for uh attending this webinars and uh if
you have any uh further questions feel
free to send it to us through email and
we'll be happy to take those questions
all right excellent
um so um thanks everyone on the call for
tuning in for this webcast
i'd also like to thank um lab roots um
for um hosting us
and um also if there were any questions
um that you didn't have time to submit
today um or if we didn't get any get to
any in the q a and these questions will
be forwarded on to the speakers
via the contact information you provide
at the time of registration and this
webcast will be available on demand lab
works for alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share the email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
also i would like to mention that if
you're interested in learning more about
cosmic smi
and um you'd like to kind of get a
flavor of the agbt experience we are
doing a
pre-agbt event called the spatial
multi-omics symposium
you can go to the events section of our
website to register for that event it is
going to be in person in florida in
orlando but it will also be
virtual as well so you can watch it um
streamed live so you'll hear from um
people at ministring um such as our
chief scientific officer joe beacham as
well as some of our customers um and
you'll learn both about some cosmic smi
experiments as well as genomic csp so
thanks everyone for joining
thank you speakers thank you vic and
chen
thanks thanks everyone
you